faut-il reouvrir les maisons closes
depuis la sortie du livre de Chantal
Brunel cette question est dans toutes
les têtes et de tous les débats sur les
violences faites aux femmes la députée
UMP dans ce livre intitulé Pour en finir
avec les violences faites aux femmes
propose la réouverture des maisons close
ce qui suscite l'indignation de beaucoup
d'associations qui luttent contre la
prostitution c'est le cas du Mouvement
du Nid dont le délégué départemental est
avec nous Albert Gaudré bonsoir merci
d'être là euh la la ré ouverture de ces
maisons closuses peut-être conçu en tout
cas c'est le point de vue de Chantal
Brunel comme comme un moyen d'encadrer
la prostitution pour vous non ben non
mais justement c'est ce terme d'encadrer
qui nous gêne et puis d'ailleurs madame
Brunel a ne parle plus de maison clos
elle parle de maison ouvertees alors bon
c'est joliment dit hein mais ça reste
quand même un bordel il faut le dire et
derrière à
l'intérieur malgré que les portes soient
ouvertes on n'y vient pas pour écouter
le le le champ des petits oiseaux il y a
quand même à l'intérieur des personnes
qui subissent 10 fois 20 fois et
davantage par jour des choses qu'elle ne
désire pas h HM alors voilà la raison
pour laquelle n vous avez évoqué la que
c'était l'année cette année c'est c'est
déclarer cause nationale contre les
violences faites aux femmes et c'est
dommage que Madame Brunel euh parle de
rouvrir ses maisons alors que par
ailleurs elle a un discours qui est
assez proche due autre pour d'autres
questions h alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire c'est interdire la prostitution
l'interdire ça ne règle rien euh tout ce
qui est tout ce qui passe par la
répression ça ne ça ne porte pas ses
fruit il y a des pays
qui qui prennent ce système vous savez
qu'il y a il y a plusieurs la la la
prostitution elle est régie sous TR sous
trois principes la prohibition la
réglementation et l'abolition mais
l'abolition c'est pas l'abolition de la
prostitution c'est assez complexe mais
c'est le système abolitionniste c'est
l'abolition de la réglementation c'était
quelque chose qui nous est arrivé du
19e mais vouloir vouloir l'interdire et
vouloir la la prohibber ça ça ne
changera rien mais vouloir l'encadrer
c'est c'est aller aussi contre ce ce que
l'on souhaite nous on voudrait un monde
sans prostitution alors évidemment on
paraît utopique quand on parle de ça
parce que il y a des clichés qui
perdurent vous les connaissez pas
d'encadrement pas d'interdiction
qu'est-ce que vous proposez alors
concrètement pour abolir la
prostitution ben le système
abolitionniste malgré qu'il soit pas
très qui qui qui qui soit pas très clair
dans son dans ses textes c'est encore
celui qui nous paraît le le moins
mauvais pour que les personnes puissent
s'en sortir donc ce que nous avons
actuellement la France l'a signé en en
1960 c'est un c'est un texte qui date de
1949 la convention de 1947 49 est
ratifiée par la France en
1960 ce texte est fondamental pour nous
parce queà l'intérieur il y a il y a des
textes qui protègent les personnes qui
sont dans la prostitution donc il y a
des processus de réinsertion qui sont
qui sont qui qui qui qui sont mentionnés
il y a aussi toute la prévention
derrière pour éviter de rentrer dans ce
processus de la
prostitution si on l' ménage ça veut
dire qu'on la reconnaît et nous la
reconnaître ça veut dire qu'elle existe
et qu' à partir de là
ben pourquoi la prostitution ne pourra
pas disparaître si elle est régl que
l'aménager dans dans les maisons
closuses comme on peut le cevoir le
concevoir Chantal Brunel c'est permettre
aussi d'empêcher l'esclavage pur et dur
de contrôler un peu ce qui se passe
entre les relations des prostituées et
leur assurer des droits aussi notamment
une assurance médicale mais je pense que
c'est là qu'elle se trompe parce que euh
les maisons closes n'est pas le système
il y a on a on a en Europe on a des
exemples qui sont intéressants là-dessus
et il faudrait qu'on les regarde ces
exemples prenons l'Allemagne elle est
elle est réglementariste prenons les
Pays-Bas et je crois que c'est l'exemple
le plus frappant celui-là les les
Pays-Bas ont adopté ce système de
réglementation en l'an 2000 et là-bas la
fameuse vitrine hollandaise je pense que
beaucoup de de téléspectateurs les
connaissent il suffit d'aller mais c'est
ces fameuses vitrines elles sont en
train de disparaître parce que les la
ville de d'Amsterdam euh trouve que ça
ne correspond pas bien au style de la
ville alors on a donc réglementer au
Pays-Bas mais au lieu de régler le
problème de la prostitution ça au
contraire fait un appel d'air ce qui
fait qu'il y a une prostitution
clandestine qui s'exerce là-bas
également dans la rue et euh donc de
façon incontrôlée donc ça ne règle pas
non plus le problème vous avez évoqué
aussi la la question de des droits et je
crois savoir que là-bas au Pays-Bas il y
a seulement 4 % des personnes qui sont
dans les maisons et qui bénéficient de
ces droits 4 % c'est pas beaucoup 59 %
des Français seraient pour l'ouverture
de ces maisons closes oui ben c'est un
sondage qui est qui est paru je pense
suite à la à la sortie du livre de
Madame Brunel mais dans une période où
l'insécurité et quelque chose qui qui
parle au français actuellement ne nous
surprend guerre que il y ait autant de
personnes qui qui demandent mais si on
rapproche si on rapproche ce chiffre des
gens qui souhaitent que la
prostitution perdure en France c'est pas
scientifique on peut pas dire que ce
sont des sondages mais on dit qu'il y a
75 à 80 % des personnes qui disent qu'il
faut que la prostitution continue parce
que il c'est le plus vieux métier du
monde parce que ça évite les viol et
cetera alors tout ça c'est faux alors on
a fait on a fait il y a a y a 3 ans
maintenant une enquête sur le client de
la prostitution et on devrait bien aller
regarder ce qui se passe en Suède madame
Brunel d'ailleurs l'évoque dans son
livre d'accord Albert gore merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur ce plateau nous
apporter toutes ces précisions